we have a place a compound we have a in
just 10 seconds this movie has already
made me think of lost the walking dead I
am Legend and the river wild someone
called Guinness since I don't think this
amount of derivative will happen this
quickly ever again but you have to do it
blindfolded anyway right so what
difference would kids make on this
journey listen to me
I'm only gonna say this once I know
Mallory's trying to get their attention
but why I only say this once
they're kids man and you'll have plenty
of time to whisper reminders of
pertinent information during this very
long trip boy you have your dog girl you
have your kitty couldn't sit in only boy
you have your dog girl you have your
kitty was the title of the children's
book my parents used when it was time
for the talk roll parents and here's the
first of many questions about the
logistics of this threat if they can
even see partially through these
blindfolds how are they 100% effective
at keeping the scary ghost thingies from
dude adding their psyche is this
unconcerned about the sound why are they
whispering have you ever been row
boating or canoeing before if you're not
paying attention your dominant arm will
row a lot stronger than your
non-dominant arm and you'll go right
into the bank over and over again so how
the is Mallory staying this street while
blindfolded it's not even like she's a
boating expert if he doesn't even
suggest that she's ever done this before
meanwhile back at Rachael Leigh Cook
studio from she's all that store was
packed things seemed serious bow you
literally have no food man Sarah
Paulsen's a great actress so it really
took an impressively awful script for
her to deliver dialogue like this don't
yet know what is causing the mass
suicides in your Russia forgetting the
question about why the whole thing
started in Russia in the first place why
are the grocery stores here so compact
also how the news get this footage
anyone that's filming this is either
about to be dead or is already
dangerously psychotic I guess the only
way it's possible is if Gyllenhaal's
character from Nightcrawler delivered it
thankfully the movie shows us an arrow
from Russia to Alaska cuz if it hadn't I
don't know how we could ever have
figured out how it jumped over Sarah
Palin's backyard fence and made its way
into the US no that was a different
symbiote based plague that sought to
destroy the lives of anyone who looked
at it and it even had weird I effect too
so I understand your confusion took you
a long time to find a studio you loved
Jesus Christ I know I just sinned the
dialogue in the scene
but it's so unnatural and cringy but I'm
just gonna add 20 extra sins here and
call it a day this is the kind of movie
you're watching this is a perfect
example having a Rando sweatsuit woman
hammered into my eyeball so we can have
some sort of connection with her when
she dies in a few minutes are you not
entertained
don't you know doctor that if you just
don't acknowledge a thing it simply goes
away so does that mean the whole
blindfold thing is a metaphor for denial
if so doesn't that make denial a good
thing since not seeing the creatures is
the only way to be safe the themes in
this movie are more muddled than subtle
and they are leaving me befuddled it's
2000 hours it is too bad it great to be
a worse then you're gonna have like
mother would have actually raised us can
you imagine how infuriating it must be
to be around these two were talking but
if that's not what you want there are
plenty of couples who are desperate to
adopt a child
Malheur is pretty pregnant here right
and she clearly had this attitude from
the beginning so why is this
conversation just coming up now Brando
sweatsuit lady is doing what I've been
keeping myself from doing for the first
10 minutes of watching this movie also
later were shown that all infected
people have their eyes do that weird
thing so why is this girl still on clear
eyes full hearts my phone is in the back
seat they use x-ring Tonica Oh
Malory eventually looks exactly at the
same spot that Jessica does but suffers
no ill effects in this movie you can
already the hell the fact that Malory is
able to prevent Jess from driving into
traffic brings up an interesting
question can't an infected person be
prevented from killing themselves I know
they've come up with all kinds of clever
ways for self harm but you could totally
restrain some motherfuckers like Simon
Pegg does with Nick Frost at the end of
Shaun of the Dead but no one even
attempts that here
don't worry man I bet they're just cans
just cans all these assholes are running
out in the open and not one of them has
been affected by the actual phenomenon
are these ghosts demons just pacing
themselves or something she went to help
you
now she's Clark and with that line we
can clearly tell that John Malkovich has
down shifted into Eragon Conair mode for
this performance convincing us why would
anyone think at this point that being
inside the house would be any safer than
outside
look movie I'm not saying you have to
explain everything but maybe explain
something things mr. nervous system I've
been seen in my clients for weeks weeks
weeks where the terror demon seriously
hanging around here for weeks but didn't
want to reveal themselves to anyone
until Larry the demon got back from
terrorizing Russia okay I've already
questioned how the hell they got the
footage to the newsroom why the hell
does the news need this tracking shot of
a goddamn horse besides reminding Malory
about her dead sister god I hate this
movie so hard
also we're about to see that viewing the
demons I'm just gonna go ahead and call
those things demons by the way on a
screen produces the same effect as
seeing them in person so it's clear that
movie chose ham-handed exposition over
logic in this scene it won't be the last
time yes because the only thing that can
combat these all-powerful supernatural
entities from coming inside a house is
their natural enemy a wooden door the
president has declared a state of
emergency and has closed our borders not
because of this attack mind you but we
wanted to keep you up on the other news
of the day and game oh I'm sorry what
you know it's that thing dr. strange
said an infinity war that led to his
ultimate demise and the catalyst to the
future phases of the MCU let me start
from the beginning the end credits scene
in 2008 iron man had a cameo by Nick
Fury and got the Circa from ancient
Christian occult beliefs that made
pregnant women encounter unborn children
is of the creatures conveniently
knowledgeable grocery store clerk is
convenient you got the pooka from Celtic
mythology Charlie is clearly much more
interested than the movie is and
explaining this phenomenon did she cut
this look on her face
whoa there sandy has anyone told you
what kind of movie you're in and that
you don't have to try this hard look at
Malkovich you can actually see the phone
in his hand
and just Sukkot wait is the movie a
metaphor for depression now is it saying
the answer to depression is to just not
acknowledge it I hate to keep beating
Sarah Paulsen's dead horse here but
we're never given enough pieces in the
movie for any of this to make sense so
nothing happened between the arrival at
the house and bedtime no snippets of
news or calls getting through or even
more theories from Charlie my point is
everyone got to this house in the middle
of the day so this immediate cut to
bedtime is weird awesome we're gonna be
jumping back and forth between these two
timelines are we about to cut to Tom
Hardy in a plane she'd better be rowing
that boat to Dunkirk oh no the birds are
going crazy
which means something I guess they're
saying the demons are close but does it
really matter if you don't look at them
this movie is titled after this goddamn
bird box but it serves very little to
the overall story what kind of law do
you practice bankruptcy when he's not
suing his neighbors man I haven't seen
this much expositional bitchiness since
the last real housewives reunion show
since you have no idea how it works okay
fine she knows her way around a shotgun
but the Foley artist doesn't because
that definitely sounds like empty shells
hitting the ground when not a single
shot has been fired great not only can
all stars here in the maternity ward he
may be an asshole but Douglas would be
excellent at cinema since wait I phrased
that wrong Douglas would be excellent at
cinemasins because he's an asshole
we saw BB wrong why would they leave dr.
Wu alone in this room they've tied him
up as a precaution but couldn't someone
sit on the other side of those monitors
so something goes wrong they can no
don't like he didn't make them look not
a chance
the world's ending baby so you never
know and this is how Machine Gun Kelly
and probably ended up dating Halsey oh
no not the wind if I know my happenings
and I like to think I do something's
about to go down or you could at least
try to see if Greg still alive right I
know there's a lot of blood but has
anyone even checked his vitals we're
never getting out of here Lita rattled
angel we interrupt this bird box movie
to bring you several minutes of Sandra
Bullock wandering aimlessly around an
expensive house at night of all the
supposed horrific images in this movie
this is definitely the one that will
haunt my dreams that's something you
can't see
but you just came out here how does Tom
even know what she did or didn't see how
does he even know what they're doing in
there Tom's omniscience is mind-boggling
hi
I've seen the truth Oh some people can
see them and not kill themselves and the
movie will totally use that information
to make an interesting and relevant Tory
point later right
seriously the sucker asks 100 questions
and leaves about 125 of them unanswered
so do the birds also go nuts if there's
an unblinded person around and if so why
weren't they making noise when he was
yelling at them before god damn these
eponymous birds are useless this was
what Netflix demanded when it pushed
this movie to the top of every Browse
page for a full month run out of food
and there's no help coming I might know
we can get more the fields market I mean
yeah did no one think about going to the
grocery store I know the logistics of
getting there are hard but Lily's trying
to say it's a revelation that there's a
market near about how come it's a death
wish the training it'll be fine yes
because Lucy's gone through the police
academy and makes her uniquely qualified
to join a bird box challenge to raid an
abandoned supermarket that's what they
teach you on like the third day how was
driving blast safe we're not that's GPS
is that GPS have the location of every
abandoned vehicle that might be blocking
their own
what about downed electric lines or
poles what about once you're in the
parking lot
even with proximity sensors this would
be a doomed mission from the start we
have the GPS luckily for the survivors
and this movie Greg just happened to
have a ton of black paint sitting around
his garage I know they were renovating
it all but even so that's this much in
black paint continue straight Tom's
ability to drive straight even with the
help of the GPS is even harder to
believe than Malory paddling swiftly
along the river remember when Ricky
Bobby tried to drive blindfolded how'd
that work out so can you see these
ghosts demons or not make up your
goddamn mind movie yes because no one
not even the crazy believer guy that's
literally outside the back door thought
to break a window and raid the local
grocery store damn it I sent a lot of
dumb fucking movies but this is the
dumbest mother stupid-ass boat movie
I've seen in a long time
okay has the store been raided or not
the bakery section is completely empty
and the end cap with all the shampoo
looks like it's been picked over but
there are clearly many items left over
especially the ones that are most useful
in a post-apocalyptic setting Charlie
said he locked up when all that went
down and the lock was still locked when
they got here so what gives there was
some extremely mild looting for cookies
and head and shoulders and then they
locked up after themselves this is
truly the happiest place on earth I
thought I'd run out of previous movies
that this one rips off but then I
remember this exact scene happens in 28
days later so I'll add it to the growing
list that already included zombie land
the happening the river wild pitch black
and quiet please nobody could have
amassed some other way sure could have
been your your babysitter and just then
a new category of post-apocalyptic
pregnant babysitter porn emerged on all
the popular sites
nanus market has some super fresh
poultry all of us are making the end of
the world
grated yeah take it from someone who's
trying to shoehorn in many many trump
jokes that just didn't work
this Trump joke does not work there is
no statistical logical or legal argument
for trying to get back there I'm with
Teddy KGB hear nothing else instead of
trying to take as much of the food back
to the humans why not just bring the
humans to the food there's something
wrong this movie is about to give us two
key pieces of information here with zero
context as to reasons were meaning first
the birds seem to go crazy and second
Charlie describes his friend as a bit
crazy
so apparently crazy people can see it
and not kill themselves and then
immediately want others to see it too
and the birds are somehow aware of who
the good guys and the bad guys are or
maybe when the creatures are nearby
but once again for those in the back why
how at this point we should probably
just all stop asking to let the movie
finish humping our legs so we can move
on with our day also though are we
really gonna make mental illness the
avenue that allows humans to live but
also turns them into psychopathic
disciples of the smoke monster are you
feeling icky yet no give it time you'll
get there there are literally millions
other ways to handle this situation and
this is definitely the dumbest but the
dude in close the door and then shoot
him if you need to Tom's primary
character trait was listed as someone
who immediately gets everyone away from
the people that are maybe but not
definitely dead
you were at a fully stocked grocery
store and you left this much room in the
vehicle how is there not food piled to
the ceiling here you've even got extra
room that's Charlie shaped the fact that
two of the supposed main characters of
this movie steal away in the middle of
the night never to be seen or referenced
again says a lot about how much this
movie cares about its audience
where's the goddamn car guys you guys
where Lucy Felix
Jesus has Mallory done a full house
check like it's possible they ran away
but she knew this instantly I've seen a
lot of post-apocalyptic movies and this
one has the easiest rating by far that
I've ever seen seriously if the little
girl doesn't get out of the boat which
is extremely
character mind you it's a breeze yeah
what the hell just shoot it hell it may
actually kill one of them for all we
know about these fucking things Dana my
deployment in Iraq of course tom has a
military background he couldn't just be
an average Joe with an incredible set of
muscles it's like how every Dwayne
Johnson movie has to explain how he was
a professional athlete or ex Special
Forces despite being currently employed
as a marine biologist hello is anyone
out there hello I wish this movie would
decide what's gonna be there's a point
here where it's trying to be a
meditative drama about relationships in
humanity but then you remember that
they're being held captive by evil space
ghosts and all the relatability flies
out the window with Olympia yeah off me
I don't believe it he's lying good
intuition but how is he lying all those
other assholes can't talk about anything
other than how you have to see the
demons but Gary comes in and presents
himself like a regular dude how could he
do that why can he do that who can he do
that
they broke in damn it they dragged tom
hollander into this too I don't think
I've ever seen a better collection of
talent in a dear movie well okay except
for Gangster Squad get up and get
character is hit in the head with a
ceramic doodad and immediately loses
consciousness for a convenient amount of
time cliche thing happens to me
I would take care of a baby and now
we've come to the problem with a
nonlinear timeline since we've already
seen sandy with two kiddos and the boat
we've known this was coming for a while
so the scene has zero tension or plot
momentum just wasted space telling us
something we already knew because we're
smart enough to literally know that one
plus one equals two I love this song
thank you
oh no the characters are getting along
and having a nice moment during a horror
movie which cannot Telegraph harder that
is about to hit the fan also can we
revisit how it's possible for psycho
Gary to hold his together this long
including casually talking about his pop
I know I too am mystified at how the
script expects us to believe that you
two would go into labor at the exact
same time why does Gary wait until now
to let his crazy out if they didn't go
into labor and everyone is distracted
what would be the plan and why go
through any of this when the objective
is just to open the windows King Gary so
are these supposed to be drawings of the
creatures is there any reason for him to
play classical music and set them out to
look at them why is he compelled to draw
at this very moment why are the birds
not bothered by his presence at this
point is there air you don't know whoa
while these demon creatures is the
predator the disturbing part of this act
isn't that he's putting live birds into
a freezer it's that the freezer is empty
enough that it can accommodate an entire
large bird cage with no problem sure
moving I was confused with just the
demonic drawings free
the birds tearing down the window
coverings and knocking Tom out thanks
for the super zoom on the eyes so I
could finally get that Gary's evil baby
I was quick to the Dementors just
happened to be lurking right outside
that particular window hoping that
someone would open it up if so really
the creepiest thing about them is how
stalkery they are Danielle McDonald was
ready to be done with this movie and
clearly was not walking around so they
closed the blinds and all but instead
enough if so why'd they previously
bother with the newspaper on the windows
and isn't the window that Olympia went
through wide open now does that mean the
parademons can come in now
yep no need to know how they survived by
themselves with two infants how they
escaped the neighborhood with no car or
GPS capabilities or anything that
occurred over the past five years
seriously nothing like a five-year gap
in time to short-circuit any immediate
tension that the movie might have been
building oh sure five years you learn to
teach echolocation but haven't figured
out something better to cover your eyes
with in a flimsy blindfold that could
loosen or get caught on something and
fall off so now all the marauding
Psychopaths have cars and they form
posses I thought they were all like lone
wolves like Gary can Gary man sure is
lucky that the two remaining survivors
are hot can you imagine if Malory ended
up with Malkovich or MGK ah yes remember
when these two fell in love and how
we're invested in their relationship
because what it meant for them to find
each other no no you don't Gus it all
happened in the last five years that
apparently we aren't allowed to know
anything about rick is a total dick
you're telling me the only way
motherfuckers made it to shangri-la is
by using a sacrificial lamb what happens
after they look the rest of the people
in the boat just throw them overboard
Jesus this story's gotten so stale and
rote and cliche that I'm actively hoping
Gary comes back from the dead to stir
some duck I know they're trying to
survive it all but what would happen if
there was a group of people in here
opening that door would assuredly kill
them right I'm just saying is it that
hard to not renounce your presence
before breaking in why does every single
one of these homes have their windows
covered with newspapers think about it
would you even have enough newspaper to
cover one window in your house the
newspapers even still exist this is it
strawberry tastes like oh no the
characters are getting along and having
a nice moment during a horror movie
which cannot Telegraph harder that's
about to hit the fan seriously maybe you
just tried to pull this 20 minutes ago
getting what out of all the houses in
all the neighborhoods in Northern
California these assholes show
specifically up here along with being
psychos are they also psychic so even
though he's been infected by the
paranormal pinkeye Tom still has enough
self-control that he can protect Mallory
I guess her sister didn't love her this
much considering she tried to drive both
of them off the road at the beginning of
the movie they've been on the river for
42 hours and I have to say I'm really
feeling like the events in this movie
might be happening in real time there's
only one way for me to navigate through
them somebody has to look here's the
problem with the somebody's gotta look
bull in this movie are they saying you
can take a quick peek and then you'll be
able to navigate the entire rabbit or
someone has to be on the lookout the
whole time despite the fact that they
could be demon food at any time because
neither explanation holds a drop of
water the birds in the Box survived this
keeping a go if you know how to ring the
bell she not to keep her eyes closed but
she didn't know to put her blindfold
back on even though it's right there on
her head she hid his Birds that's where
we're headed okay we just followed got
stuck are there know where the birds in
the woods though I get that the compound
said they had a bunch of birds but do
they have all the birds several minutes
of voices wind bird spirits leaves none
of which have any explanation so I'm
gonna give this two fingers one big ol
skip and 30 extra sins
dun-dun-duh the safe place is the school
for the blind
wait what how does that a twist what
does it solve for the creature scared of
the blind the blind have superpowers
against them just because the blind
can't see the creatures doesn't make the
sighted any safer right also is this
school in the middle of the woods at the
end of a river what kind of a sick joke
is it to build a school for the blind
one of the most remotest and most
difficult this places to navigate to oh
look it's an outdoor sanctuary that
somehow doesn't allow the demons in
because of the foliage and birds and
whatnot and that makes total sense this
movie battery somehow the fact that
Mallory's gynecologist is in this exact
spot more than five years after the
event is the most disorienting part of
this movie and let me tell you that's
saying something
I believe they've been abducting black
people brainwashing them make it a work
form as sex slaves
oh sorry much so you have my money
Thor's fuel and all she wrote in on how
much water are we there yet no are we
there yet
no oh yeah yeah I need to talk to you
about the Rapids is this the biggest one
on well the biggest one is gauntlet
that's five plus that's off the scale
don't look at the Mallory
Henry Hayes feed O'Connor's